mushrooms are one of my all-time
favorite ingredients
i use chestnut mushrooms with the beef
short ribs because i love their firm
texture and nutty taste but there's a
huge range of other mushrooms that are
great for slow cooked dishes
and when it comes to buying them there's
one expert green grocer who's a fountain
of knowledge borough marcus fred foster
he started off on the memphis dead still
in pimlico really he had a salad stall
with other 20 years of experience he
could actually write his own mushroom
encyclopedia
mushrooms as soon as you pick them
the moisture starts coming out of them
so you need to buy them when they're
fresh certain products you smell for
flavour
and they tend to be fruits
mushrooms don't smell nice at all they
smell kind of metallic really
so you have to use your eyes as your
guide of what you buy with mushrooms
really really important wild mushrooms
are literally grown wild in the forest
they're just quality wherever they are
this is morel mushroom
a fantastic product so hard to find in
the world it's almost got an apricoty
type of flavour earthy woody and of
course as you cook it the flavour
increases for extra flavor and texture
highly prized morels are ideal when
added to slow cooked stews and
casseroles as are the trumpet de la more
which have a deliciously rich flavor
another wild type to try is the
chanterelle its subtle fruity flavor is
delicious and perfect fried with butter
parsley and garlic when you're dealing
with wild mushrooms you need to clean
them it can be quite a slow process
it's with a soft brush don't don't use
water never use water with mushrooms it
deteriorates the mushroom rapidly
oyster mushrooms are very meaty mushroom
just a lovely silky smooth flavour
really nice how do you tell
whether it's fresh those gills are
bright never cut an oyster mushroom
always tear it look at the whiteness of
that beautiful that would be grey if it
was old
although also found wild oyster
mushrooms are more commonly cultivated
along with a similar type the enoki
their delicate taste is great in salads
and soups
finally fred saved the best until last
and of course the pinnacle
is the truffle
they are really really sought after the
smell is so intense that smell
it's hard to describe because it's such
a unique smell the more expensive the
truffle the more intense the smell so
that's why you use such a small amount
on a dish it's amazing the way they get
these they used to use pigs of course
they don't do that anymore they use dog
steel but because the pigs used to eat
them all this magical tasting fungi is
by weight one of the most expensive
foods in the world it's phenomenal eaten
raw shaved over pastel or risottos or
drizzle of truffle or turn slow cooked
stews into something out of this world
people are actually scared of mushrooms
aren't they so it's amazing really they
shouldn't be because
take away the fear and just close your
eyes and taste them they're just amazing
they are amazing
[Music]
slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes the secret is
to lock in all those flavors at the
start and let the ingredients do their
thing as it cooks
these are beef short ribs and there's
basically five to six bones
across there
and as the short rib cooks it sticks
that bone the bone implants flavor and
the meat just sort of melts cooks slowly
gives it that nice level intensity
slice alongside the bone straight down
you can see that marbling that sort of
disappears and disintegrates i'm cooking
them in a roasting tray get it on the
heat until nice and hot
season these short ribs beautifully
olive oil in bone on the top
we'll start coloring that in
[Music]
really important to give the beef short
ribs a really nice sear
if you didn't brown the meat off
it goes in the oven
and it looks like boiled meat so you
really want that nice dark rich coloring
just cut the garlic
in half slide that down the side that's
going to give that beef an amazing
flavor
[Music]
to give body to the sauce stir in a
heaped teaspoon of tomato puree
i'm just hitting the bottom of the pan
with that tomato puree
and we call it
cooking out that smell of puree
otherwise it just goes in there raw and
it gives this sort of
tartness to the braised short ribs
red wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor
makes a big difference when you reduce
the red wine down by half because it
gives that nice
dark rich
intensity
look at my garlic
that is just gonna sweeten everything up
incredible
stock in
beef stock perfect chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bring it up to the ball
to lock in all that flavor as the beef
ribs slow cook cover them so they
braised from the bottom and steamed from
the top into the oven two and a half
hours
170 to 180 degrees
in she goes
the great thing about slow cooking is
you do most of the work in advance and
then put your feet up
five or ten minutes before the beef
short ribs come out of the oven start
your garnish this is light cured
pancetta
we want nice thick
nice big thick sticks of crispy bacon
[Music]
these are delicious chestnut mushrooms
i'm not going to slice them
i'm just going to cut them in half
but look at the color on those lardons
now all the whites raw fat have
disappeared the lardons have shrunk
right down
and all we've got there now is the
proper bacon
mushrooms in
beautiful
so the mushrooms get seasoned from the
bacon
i'm pan frying these separately to the
beef so they remain crisp and have a
different texture
[Music]
leave that to cool down
now
this is like christmas day for me when
you unwrap that fall once you see what's
underneath it
[Music]
wow
they smell
incredible
lift and place
on your tray
beautiful
to make a fantastic rich deep sauce
press the soft roasted garlic through a
sieve into the cooking juices
all that nice
pureed garlic coming through there
because that is going to make the most
amazing
flavor
scrape all of that off the sieve
nice
then
just start
sieving all that lovely brazing liquor
in
that smells delicious
take your sauce
and just glaze
do them individually
they deserve that respect
spoon on
your bacon and your mushrooms
beautiful
be generous with these mushrooms i'm
telling you
they taste amazing
flat leaf parsley all that freshness
over those amazing ribs incredible never
ever be embarrassed about going to your
butcher and asking for cheap cuts
because the results
are incredible amazing beef braised
short ribs
with bacon and mushrooms
it's mushroom and leek pasta
this fantastic fast and simple pasta
dish made with everyday ingredients just
goes to prove you can eat good food
whenever you want
really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently swimming
away ready for the pasta
while the water comes to the boil start
the sauce by slicing mushrooms first off
fingers one in front two behind
up and down
then add olive oil to a hot frying pan
[Music]
i want that nice color on the mushrooms
off the heat literally 10 seconds
and when you toss something really
important you get all the ingredients at
the end of the pan
push down and pull back
that noise that's
that's all the water coming out of the
mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
[Music]
then prepare your leeks
just take your knife
and go down
through the center turn it over
and again into quarters
see all that opening up and then just
rinse the top of that to get rid of any
potential dirt or sand
it just breaks up into nice little
quarters
add
all that leek
into those mushrooms
beautiful
and now the secret is to get rid of that
water inside the leek
as it cooks down all the water's gone
you just left that really nice intense
flavor
garlic's got nice and crispy
now we're going to add a touch of
chicken stock in there
beautiful
lasagna sheets i'm just going to drop
the sheets
in to the water
lasagna sheets are an unusual choice for
a dish like this but they work
brilliantly although any type of pasta
you've got in the cupboard will do
and just twist that pan
that stops any pasta actually sticking
to the bottom of the pan
chicken start to reduce down by half
and it's almost delays the bottom of the
pan basically washed all that wonderful
flavor off turn the gas down
and add a couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up to the bowl and let it simmer
for three to four minutes
now
the secret with the pasta is just taking
it out a little early
so you've got that nice texture
hold up the sheet and just nip it
and you can feel your fingers in the
center it's ready
turn the sauce down
and lay
these beautiful sheets
of lasagna into that sauce
i'm just going to turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing sauce
finish with chopped fresh tarragon
it's a delicious herb it goes
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit and almost sort of
infuse
to serve i'm making a quick bruschetta
by toasting fresh chipata bread two nice
slices drizzle that
in olive oil
a little bit of garlic
just rub the bread
the crust as well crust is what really
takes that garlic
now
pan for the bread little touch of olive
oil
as it starts to smoke
bread in
[Music]
but look at the pasta now it's been
stained by that amazing sauce to serve i
want a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream then i'll take my pasta
just twist it
and let it sit on top
that tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on
and that's the beauty about something so
simple they can be done in 20 minutes
with everyday ingredients a stunning
pasta dish
adding easy and versatile dishes like
this to your repertoire is what cooking
at home is all about so you can always
make great tasting food at the drop of a
hat
you